[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم اوكرانيا تؤكد ان مدينه
خيرسون باتت تحت سيطرتها الكامله ومسكوت
على الانتهاء عمليه انسحاب قواتها من
الضفه اليمنى لنهر درو وتقول ان خيرس ستظل
رغم ذلك جزء من روسيا حين عوده انفجارات
للانهيارات في جسر
وكفوفك على نهر
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تعترف باستخدام جهاز
المخابرات الداخليه قاعده بيانات شركات
الاتصالات في تعقب عمل صحفيين خلال
تحقيقات امنيه وجنائيه معلله ذلك بالجراء
المهم في المحافظه على امن الدوله واللجنه
التحقيق الامميه في جنوب تواصل الاستماع
لشهادات بشان الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحترفه
الاول من نوعه منذ توالي ماكرون فتره
ولايته الثانيه اضراب عام يشل حركه باريس
في وسائل النقل العامه بعد ما دعت اليه
النقابات العماليه للمطالبه بزياده الاجور
حيث شمل بشكل اساسي كل خطوط المترو الى
جانب بعض المرافق الاخرى ما تسبب في تعطل
كبير لحركه السكان والسياح واستعوده الجدل
بشان قانون الاجور وثقع بعد موجه استقالات
مديريه من تويتر الى الناس
ما لم يتم تحقيقه عائدات الماليه اكبر
وذلك بعد بدايه مضطربه للملياردير
الامريكي في موقع التواصل الاجتماعي قال
خلالها النسبه عدد موظفيه شركه وسرح
مواطنه كبار الموظفين وامر الباقي بتوقف
عن العمل من المنزل الى اللقاء